there are bad signals everywhere that
ben affleck is out as the dceu's batman
so based on the information we've got
and all those bat rumors
let's take a look at the three best and
three worst actors that could replace
him in the role
when ben affleck stepped down as writer
director of the batman warner brothers
handed off those duties to matt reeves
whose credits include multiple chapters
in the planet of the apes reboot trilogy
it's been speculated that reeves is
adapting the comic book arc batman year
one
he's denied that his script focuses on
that story but there are indications
that a younger
rawer version of batman is on deck 28
year old english actor jack o'connell
got his big break when he starred in
2014's unbroken
and since then his name has been on many
a short list for notable starring roles
he would be an unconventional choice for
this project considering his lack of
tentpole experience and name recognition
but that's just the point
if talk of the younger batman is true
then dc should take a non-traditional
approach when casting
armie hammer checks a lot of boxes he
has experience in action films like the
lone ranger and the man from uncle
he's delivered incredible performances
in films like the social network and
call me by your name
at 32 he's relatively young he's also
got the stature
six foot five athletic build and square
jaw on paper
the guy can be batman in fact on paper
he was
batman albeit briefly in george miller's
scuttle justice league but he shouldn't
be on anyone's short list for the reboot
we're going to push these dc people
farther than they are ever going to be
comfortable with
and then the dc people showed up and
looked around and they were like this is
farther than we're comfortable
affleck's possible departure gives
warner brothers the opportunity to
boldly take the dc eu in a new and
exciting creative direction
casting army hammer as the new batman
would feel like more of the same
a little too traditional a little too on
the nose
a little too boring mainstream viewers
became aware of ris ahmed when he landed
a breakout
role on the hbo miniseries the night of
as the show unfolded ahmed displayed a
startling ability to reveal new profound
layers of his character in each episode
and he's since gone on to be recognized
as one of the most unique
young talents working in hollywood today
ahmed also totally nailed roles in such
various films as night crawler rogue one
and venom
he's got leading man looks and he's
proven that he has the acting chops to
play the caped crusader
casting this rising talent would be a
great move in forging a new
on-screen identity for bruce wayne jake
gyllenhaal is a gifted actor who has
gotten close to superhero roles in the
past
he was rumored to be in consideration
for the lead role in spider-man 2 when
it looked like toby maguire's back
problems would preclude
him from returning for the sequel he was
also reportedly in the running for
batman begins
more than anyone else on this list
gyllenhaal has been the subject of
replacing affleck rumors with some
industry insiders assuming it was all
but a done deal
however to the disappointment of his
legions of fans he has denied the rumors
in an interview with china news asia
when asked if he was taking on the
batman role he said point blank
the answer to that question is no no
like if you're hanging a guy by a string
right and he's like hanging upside down
and you're in a bat suit
yeah i'd they'd be like who are you you
know and i'd be like i'm batman are you
kidding me
with critically acclaimed roles in
character studies like inside lou and
davis a most violent year
and a little space opera called star
wars oscar isaac
has proven himself to be a bankable
talent it's been reported that isaac has
already met with warner brothers to
discuss a mystery role in the batman
it's unlikely that this mystery role is
the lead because if this reboot is
focusing on a younger crime fighter
isaac wouldn't fit the bill however the
storyline probably hasn't been set in
stone by the studio just yet since matt
reeves has publicly stated that his film
won't focus on any one story
it's possible that the new bruce wayne
won't have to be the young crime fighter
from the year one comic
he has also mentioned that he wants to
make this film a noir-driven
definitive batman story and that he went
on a deep dive revisiting all of his
favorite comics
this could leave the door open for an
older actor and in that case
isaac would be a casting home run
reigning sexiest man alive idris elba
is the same age as ben affleck if warner
brothers truly wants to take their dc
properties in a new creative direction
they're going to need somebody who can
make a long-term commitment and that
means casting somebody younger than
affleck
elba has appeared in many high-profile
films including marvel cinematic
universe blockbusters as heimdall
in every one of his movie and tv
appearances he brings charisma and
intensity that can't be ignored for the
role of batman however with the dc eu
where it is at this particular moment
elba simply isn't a fit